うぬぼれ
一番基本的な技から教えていきますよねします好きですか
基本的なおとうスタイルですはい
これで広技を繰り出していくとああなるほど
なっちゃうんですけどとか言っ
じゃあ実際ねやってみようと思いくださいまず皆さんに覚えてほしいはたま
シングルマザーという技ですようん
あまり小技目には突っ込まないようにあんなこのはいすいませんけどあまりこう特殊な
スキルを要求さんがいわずなんですけどまぁ
けどやっぱ所詮者の方には凄い難しいですねじゃあやっぱり
内閣そういう1級とか太ってないとちょうどやっぱりこう
手首努力粉砕骨折じゃあやっぱやっぱ素彦
とガードだからお茶を買った曲と言っている
じゃあさっそくこのシングルバーナーの技
くださいはいシングルマザーでは早速ご覧いただきますはいお願いしますよではどうぞ
体が軽かった
先生がちょっと実際にやってるねはい神ゲーなんだっていうのはない
ああ
それは難しい場所戦車にしてはとてもなぜかすいません
対応
いいかなねアンクルほどあああああっ
座部からねまあこれ医者がコーナーでこすりであれば儲けたい
あああああっそうそうないんすよや鯉個別かねぇ
はーんなるほどあったらん
あぁあの子の os ありまずをして死刑ここでクラッチを組むなるほど
柄 big cats を構え
で9月んだからアーティ外れるであ
でで実際こうなないんだけど3阿部など行こうかーなるほど剥がせばなるほどなんで
この3ステップで覚えてねはい
なぜパートナーんここでしっかりクラッチする入って蔵から
クラッチからアーツに入るジャッジアーチ最後にしっかり洗い bing
新井とフラッチアーチから意味ソースのねクラッチ払いアーユル
これがアース首を回しの基本になるほど
実際に農業をやってみようかお願いしますよろしくお願いですよ
であるマイ箸も区議団が底値買いです
う指摘見えるっ
varivas じゃない
エナ
動かねぇパカッと割れだけで
あずきまたずマンスやってるわけじゃないんだよはいてんまんですよ
あの
理科で使うピンの可能そのプラスクールでやると変わらないんだよ
ちゃんと君のために端折ってきたからねありがとうございますああああああ最新酒の井
やろチョップスティックですね
ブービーイカロスにょんじゃそう
シングルまだやってもらえるといいなと思います
ん
クラッチ数稼ぎですよくないガッツ ok あなーあれば
ハウス極刑
暗いビスってねできる人だということか
リバースまでバースんが目指すしてるのは悲しいねこういうことですけどそうでこうし
てこうして大画像じゃないんですよね
でもダブルタッチ力ダブルタッチできたらすごいちょっと cm で見たんでパパン際
に
うまいですよはい
アーチの筆であります
ロ過ぎるマザーのポイントは
グラフらしい
味ん
立っ